hey what's happening my name is samuel
leeds and today
i'm going to be giving you a copy of my
latest book
which is a case studies 30 case studies
of very very very successful property
investors
and each chapter is their story
this isn't a book on samuel leeds and
all my stories and everything that i've
done
this is a book about people that i've
helped trained and mentored
who've become financially free some of
them have done it in months
some of them have done it in years uh
and this book i think the reason is so
fantastic and the reason
i only launched it today and it's
already had hundreds and hundreds of
downloads
is because this like whether you've got
listen if you've got a lot of money
or if you've got no money there's people
in here that started with money
there's people like josh where's josh
his picture's gonna be somewhere maybe
on the back there he is
in the hat there he is josh who is
homeless
you know people like jl spooner who's
turning over a million pounds a year in
her nightclub there she is
her story of how to do what she did
exactly
so it's really easy to get overwhelmed
with all the different strategies
you know service accommodation hmos buy
refurbished refinance deal sourcing
lease option agreements rent to rent as
long as you try to work out what you
should do
what should your plan be and you might
see me
he's been in property 12 years making
millions of pounds
that's done all of them over the years
you think well that doesn't help
what should you do there's going to be
someone in here
that you can relate to there's going to
be someone in here where you're like you
know what
i'm i'm going to follow in their
footprints and it's so much easier to
become successful
when you are you know it's like if you
want to go on a journey imagine if it's
snowing
and someone's already walked in the snow
you can just walk in their footsteps
here are 30 real life
case studies okay this is this is the
back
by the way you can have this for free
i'm not like trying to sell this i've
written this as a passion project i've
written this
because i just turned 30 years old
yesterday was my 30th birthday
thank you for the lovely birthday
messages by the way and on my 30th
birthday i thought you know what
i really want to start leaving a legacy
now i'm not going to focus so much on me
and my wealth and my growth and trying
to build my empire
rather than trying to create my empire
how about if i help a whole bunch of
other people build their empires
and help a whole bunch of other people
you know become become successful and i
have been doing that over the years um
but each chapter there's 30 chapter
chapters to resemble my 30th birthday my
30 years on this planet earth
30 chapters and each chapter is from one
of these guys
with their hot top tips it says 30
inspirational
property investors case studies a case
study is a real life story with the
numbers
the details with hot tips
it's packed with hot tips from 30
different people
that have all got one thing in common
they're smashing it as property
investors
so you want to smash it this year as a
property investor you want to become
financially free
you want to know the difference is
between the people that succeed and the
people that don't
read this book and you can see the
stories and there's going to be someone
that you can relate to
my wife actually i'll see if she's
around and uh i'll let her say a couple
words but my wife speaking that this is
the most powerful book
from all the books that i've written in
property because all the other books
might be a how-to strategy or
you know this is how you do whereas this
is just all the all these guys giving
you a how-to
let me see amanda um this book you said
is the best book
yes i've done why do you say that i say
that because there's so many different
stories in there lots of people that you
can relate to
and lots of people that you can learn
from so what do you think of the guys in
the book
i think they're awesome they've done
really really well so if you were
thinking of downloading this as a free
kindle
what would you think about it i'd just
do it just do it download it download it
thanks man she's amazing man is killing
it as well maybe she should be in the
block
but this is dirty completely independent
stories
case studies all of the tips all of the
strategies
from how they've become successful so
that you can ultimately do the same
thing
so if you haven't got a kindle you think
i can't get it i haven't got a kindle
don't worry because if you download it
for free
it will go straight on to your
smartphone or your computer whatever
device you want you don't need a kindle
device
you can get it i'll leave a link in the
description where you can just click it
you don't have to
need to put your card details in you
need to pay a penny
you can just get a free copy right now
now this is very limited
amazon are doing a special offer on it
um so this is very very limited just i
don't know i don't know i think this
might be a day or two so do it
right now um on one condition all i ask
is that if you download it took a lot of
time
putting it compiling all these stories
together and getting all this written
took a lot of time
so all i ask is download it read it
enjoy it is this oh my goodness jamie
higgs
oh man he's doing brr deals in wales
oh man the figures you wouldn't believe
you wouldn't believe the figures
um anthony's story anthony anthony
this guy anthony wilmot he
he just bought a castle okay when we met
when he was when we met like he he was
working at sainsburys
and now he owns a castle so if you're
thinking actually you know what how i
mean all of these guys
i could go through all the stories this
this um
this this lady was my school teacher and
now she's now she's killing it in
property
this guy came from africa slaria leone
as an orphan he had nothing
this guy um wrote a massive big hit for
drake
you know drake uh the song was one dance
he wrote the song one dance
got a lot of money off it made a lot of
money wanted to invest in property so
some of these guys didn't start with
nothing uh john started he came to my um
my training program he was at university
when he finished university never had to
have a job
you know all of these stories this this
guy was wealthy already
this guy tony tony was wealthy already
this guy was not
this guy was working at a petrol station
he was working in a petrol station
with nothing his mom passed away and he
wanted to do something and leave a
legacy
he had a very small amount of money left
from his mom
and he wanted to do a proud and now he's
built a portfolio he's financially free
scaled it really well learn what he did
you know
all these all these stories this guy's a
pastor at the bottom so
so many different stories men women
different backgrounds different ages
different races using different
strategies
so grab a copy grab your copy do it
quickly
get the link it's completely free but
all i ask
is that you leave a review you know
leave a review on amazon
say a few words about it about about the
book because this is honestly
a top quality book so download it leave
a review i really appreciate it
i can't wait to see the reviews coming
in and this is the book that i'm most
proud of
to date so far throughout my career as
an author so
enjoy and thank you so much get it right
now
download it will literally take you one
minute on amazon we got to lose and then
it just sits there forever
and you can just read it you can refer
to it you can connect with these people
and you can ultimately do exactly the
same as what they did so
god bless thanks so much get it right
now